s'il est à légaliser le cannabis quels
effets sur le trafic de stupéfiants ça
c'est la grosse question les vieux
voyous les lieux trafiquants vous disent
régulièrement mais s'il veut se
débarrasser du problème qu'il légalise
il bouche on le trou de la sécurité
sociale
si vous légaliser le cannabis il va se
produire plusieurs choses la première
c'est que l'état ne va pas forcément
vendre un produit doté d'un thc la
substance active à l'intérieur de
l'herbe et du cannabis d'un niveau très
élevé l'état va forcément dire bon ben
on va pas vendre un produit trop fort
donc à partir de là vous avez déjà une
porte vous l'imaginez bien pour les
trafiquants qui vont te dire maintenant
on va mettre sur le marché un produit
plus fort et vous verrez on va trouver
preneur deuxièmement l'état ne pourra
jamais vendre aux mineurs or vous le
savez tous ce type de drogue cannabis
herbe chiite etc sont consommés par des
consommateurs de plus en plus jeunes
donc là forcément il y aura à ce moment
là un espèce de marché parallèle qui va
se développer et le troisième ça me
paraît clair que cette multinationale
toutes ces petites pme de de la drogue
qui sont installés sur le territoire et
qui finissent par former une vaste
multinationales ne resterons pas les
bras croisés si on leur dit maintenant
c'est en vente libre
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire mais
forcément ils vont se recycler dans les
produits plus dur est donc vous aurez
une augmentation des points
de deal où on pourra se procurer cocaïne
héroïne des choses qui jamais ne seront
légalisés par le temps
au monde